aujourd'hui le président de la
république a accepté le titre de premier
et unique chanoine d'honneur et a pris
possession de l'install en la basilique
saint jean de latran
il ne s'agit aucunement d'une obligation
institutionnelle puisque le premier
article de notre constitution se borne à
rappeler que la france est une
république laïque qu'elle assure
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction de religion et
qu'elle respecte toutes les croyances
tandis que l'article 2 de la loi de 1905
et non ce que la république ne reconnaît
aucun culte
il s'agit plutôt d'une donnée nième
dévoiement de la laïcité au profit de
communisme communautariste qui affaiblit
notre république que le président en
tant que candidat avait dévoilé en
février 2017 quand il regrettait que la
loi ouvrant le mariage aux couples du
même sexe n'est humilier une partie des
catholiques ou en avril dernier quand il
déploré quand il déclaré vouloir réparer
le lien qui s'est abîmé entre l'église
et l'état
le titre de chanoine du latran dont le
président prendra officiellement
possession est un titre laïque qui n'a
aucune dimension spirituelle mais
uniquement une signification honorifique
est historique
c'est une distinction vous l'avez dit
qui revient automatiquement au chef de
l'état français depuis henri iv vous
l'avez souligné
et tous les présidents de la république
l'ont été même si tous n'ont pas fait le
voyage pour aller le chercher pour être
très précis
historiquement je voulais bien entendu
vous dire pour terminer que s'il n'y a
pas lieu de polémiquer que l'état
dialogue avec toutes les forces vives
car qui peut nier que l'histoire et
l'histoire est que les religions font
partie de l'histoire
d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur regardez
il ya saint louis au dessus de vous qui
vous protège
merci madame la ministre vous avez
engagé une réflexion sur les pensions de
réversion est depuis une semaine vous
est expliqué sur ce sujet vous avez
notamment affirmé que vous ne toucherait
pas aux pensions déjà versés et que la
qui serait maintenue malgré tout sachez
que l'ouverture de ce débat suscite de
nombreuses inquiétudes
vous le savez la pension de réversion
concerne à 90% des femmes
oui il est vrai l'espérance de vie est
plus importante pour une femme comme
nous le savons toutes et tous ici mais
il s'agit aussi par cette pension de
réversion d'améliorer la situation de
beaucoup de femmes qui ont eu des
carrières incomplètes ou avec des
différences de salaire importantes avec
les hommes
la présence de ces sujets 'l'annonce
cette réforme des pensions de réversion
les retraités sont une fois de plus
pointés du doigt et se retrouve dans
l'incertitude
ainsi plutôt vous annoncerez beau
orientation plutôt vous pourrez les
rassurer comme tous les aspects du
système de retraite nous devons poser
sur la table
cette question des pensions donation
évidemment pas pour les faire
disparaître
on peut jouer à se faire peur mais il en
est absolument pas question
mais pour faire en sorte que chaque euro
contribué puisse au fur et à mesure du
temps permettre le même produit pour
ceux qui sont à la retraite
en aucune façon monsieur le sénateur je
veux le dire la façon la plus claire
possible
le gouvernement ne travailleraient sur
des mesures qui viendrait amoindrir ou
remettre en cause les pensions de
réversion en aucune façon
mais l'année prochaine après une année
de consultations l'année prochaine
ensemble et ce sera un très beau débat
très beau débat public un très beau
débat parlementaire j'en suis sûr il
nous faudra faire en sorte de sauver
notre système de pensions durablement
peut-être même d'en profiter pour
prendre en compte des questions
relatives à la dépendance
lesquels n'ont pas fini d'être devant
nous
[Musique]